it's the day-to-day life that you could
not imagine today reading the actual
newspaper seems to bring back into
current context and that's what a lot of
people got a kick out of you know
they'll sit there and it's like they if
they move back into that time and
they're actually living the same time
that their grandparents or
great-grandparents were there 14 years
ago retired engineer Tom Tran escy
started scanning old newspapers and then
making them searchable free of charge
online now we got the radio the
television the internet so I mean back
then that was it
Tran is Keys website which he runs out
of his home in the small town of Fault
in New York has grown into one of the
largest digital collections of historic
newspapers anywhere in the world
there's nobody helping me on that
one-man band consider the Library of
Congress's newspaper site chronicling
America the National Endowment for the
Humanities has awarded twenty two
million dollars in grants for the
project and there are now five million
newspaper pages on the site Tom Tran
iski has 22 million newspaper pages on
his site and he spent nothing but his
own time and money Tran is key site also
gets about double the amount of web
traffic with six million pageviews per
month
these people are on there 24/7 during
the nighttime as the hours change I got
people from the foreign countries coming
on they're looking up stuff the capacity
of computers to locate keywords buried
anywhere in an old newspaper has opened
a vast body of knowledge to researchers
before old newspapers were digitized
they were photographed and rolled up
into microfilm even though the data
might have existed in that newspaper you
wouldn't find it because there's just so
many walls of film you gotta look
through to find it a little bit of text
the advent of scanners that read
microfilm made it possible to make a
digital copy of an old newspaper without
going back to the original paper version
Tran escy who's a high school graduate
purchased his first microphone scanner
for 3500 dollars in a fire sale in 2003
he installed a keyword recognition
program set up a network of PCs to do
the heavy processing and began uploading
the images to a server that's located in
the gazebo right on his front deck once
the computers come along people would
just type into the search in
the name it would find it in a newspaper
and they would get something that it's
instantaneous he can do it from home and
it doesn't cost him a nickel of the 500
papers available on the site the largest
in terms of page volume is the Brooklyn
daily eagle the Brooklyn daily eagle is
the best as far as headlines goals the
pictorials what they covered and the in
depth of information they went out and
got the daily Eagle was among the most
widely read and influential newspapers
in 19th century America poet Walt
Whitman wrote over 800 items for the
paper and served as its editor from 1846
to 1847 war the daily Eagle had the
largest circulation of any evening paper
in the United States the Brooklyn Public
Library spent two years and about
$400,000 digitizing just the first
sixty-two years the daily Eagles run
which totaled about a hundred and fifty
thousand pages that was back in 2003 for
the last ten years the library has been
trying to raise money to finish the job
in the meantime Tom Tran escy digitized
the entire 115 year run of the newspaper
basically did the project all myself
it took me approximately four months to
do the complete newspaper from start
scanning to the finished product which
the OCR imaged would recognized the
Brooklyn Public Libraries daily Eagle
site and the Library of Congress is
chronicling America meet professional
cataloging standards they have fewer key
word recognition errors and they're
easier to search for casual users Tran
is keys website which includes swimming
fish and the occasional live video
stream of squirrels eating corn on its
front deck looks nothing like that of an
institutional library we have also have
a picture of myself as an old spider on
there and it's called the original web
crawler so you can come to my site and
say this is Gaudi it's crazy
I've never come back here that's not the
point of it the point is the newspapers
that I have available for free
forget the interface once you will hit
the search button all that stuff
disappears you get to see the newspaper
there have been about a hundred and
fifty thousand different newspapers in
America going back to colonial times
many of them still languishing in
archive stacks and microfilm rolls out
of reach for keyword recognition
software I'm not going to make really a
big dent in it I'm doing a lot but
there's so much newspapers out there is
phenomenal I get a lot of satisfaction
making people happy finding the
information it's just that it's really
nice looking back in time and reading
about what's going on